[Music]
[Applause]
so we we picked up many different themes
there about the role of capitalism and
the need for society to function a
certain way we picked up the romantic
tradition we picked up the issue of uh
sex becoming commodified through
pornography but then also
anyone who was not participating in the
great heterosexual
view was seen as purely concerned with
sex so there's a lot of issues
but i i want to come to the first theme
that we're going to deal with and ask
about
why would people think there was a
necessary condition
uh that that you know was built into uh
sex being attached to love why would we
think there's a necessary connection
between love and sex well as i said uh
earlier actually uh we only thought that
because that's what we were taught from
about 1920. i don't actually
believe that there's any connection
between love and sex at all
uh in fact i've often thought they were
opposites and i don't i'm not alone in
that the victorians thought they were
opposites for a start
but also the greeks did and this is
little known because everybody loves the
story aristophanes myth about you know
um
splitting a human being they used to
have four legs four you know they were
split down the middle and then they find
each other again and the myth is quoted
everywhere in all books that love sex
saying oh this is amazing this is
finding your soulmate but actually
um aristophanes was talking
really only about the love that a man
can have for a boy
which that was the supreme love
and if you you know hate her set you'd
like you'd like you'd like this
heterosexual sex was really considered
beyond the pale i mean lesbians came
second they were okay because they were
a bit spiritual if you like they liked
each other as friends they had to be
friends forever but heterosexual sex was
really no good at all
and um what they thought though was
really good was failure
and philia just basically means
friendship but it's more than friendship
because they believed that friendship
was about two equals it was about mutual
respect care for one another and they
believed that friendship lasted forever
whereas eros ha just lasted for a moment
or two and it was all about loving a
beautiful body which you would enjoy and
use and then that was that and well
actually when i read that i thought well
that i feel is completely true i also
read recently the most fantastic
definition of real love
that i have ever read it's by pascal
it's um
connectors to cur
knowledge of the heart
and uh connect
is not like our word uh knowledge it's
not about facts
it's about being present with somebody
else it's about
paying attention to somebody else
being there
and i think when we love someone it's a
kind of recognition
of a sort of essence of that person you
know them you know them
and i think that real love is a sort of
knowledge
whereas i think sex
sex is the very opposite of that the
less you know about somebody the sexier
it is which is why porn is so sexy it's
because they're just wearing these masks
any inner life is so unsexy
you know if you hear somebody's worried
about oh i don't know their children's
child's doing badly at school hey you're
not going to be having sex that night
are you
real feelings you know really unsexy i'm
i'm going to take a hunch that john
doesn't agree with that and in fact
and in fact and in fact
you said something earlier on about
it not being unsexy and it not being
distancing to become more familiar to
know someone better so
you might think that familiarity breeds
consent as far as you're concerned well
no it's it's it's a play between the two
as anybody who knows if you think about
the erotic i think that that that is
clearly true but yeah i would take a far
earthier line than than all this you
know
in the bible for example you need to
know somebody is is to have sex with
them and that is that you know the the
idea that there's no
link at all
between uh
sex and knowledge seems to me to be
wrong it seems to be an incredibly
dualistic way of looking at things you
know as if our liking and loving
people had nothing to do with their
bodily manifestations at all actually
their bodily manifestations including
language are the only things we've got
to go on you know there's more than that
it's the gateway to the soul
but i think that inversely the soul
comes into sex it's the sense of
something hidden
if if you like and i i worry that olivia
is only seeing a sexy you know a very
debased version of sex which you are are
rightly
um objecting to and you know i i don't
want to concede that it's somehow
natural that young boys are getting off
on images of violence against women i
think that's perverse it's it's
something has gone horribly wrong and
and i i think while obviously it's true
that you know not every sexual
attraction involves mad love the idea
that it doesn't involve
some kind of liking some sense of trust
something you're not put off by your
drawn towards it seems to me just a
simplification that everything is much
more comp you know if it wasn't complex
sex and relationships wouldn't be so
difficult but the emotional the
intellectual the physical are all
infused with each other yeah so i i i'm
taking that as uh you know the strong
view that there's a kind of communing
with each other that is for you part of
of sex and and really i think you're
also resisting olivia's view by saying
that
you know it becomes rather unsexy when
you objectify it becomes rather less
satisfying when people are just in it
for the sport in the 60s
so i'm certainly not advocating um
a world in which
sex can only be enjoyable within a
loving relationship
of course not i mean i was
as a feminist in the
throughout the 80s
you know we there's a lot of mythology
about what you might term second wave
feminism but we just call it feminism
we actually invented uh the idea of
sexual liberation for women by saying
in fact it was one of our demands of the
women's liberation movement that women
had a right to self-determination in
terms of our sexuality and whether that
meant demanding
uh
different types of sex within
heterosexual relationships monogamy
non-monogamy um or celibacy it didn't
matter but what we said was that women
have been told that sex is a duty sex is
most sexual experiences um for for women
um
first sexual experiences are not
positive which is a terrible
thing to think about
um and
you know the the old the old kind of
joke of what does a lesbian bring on a
first date a pickford's removal van and
her cat you know it's it's kind of a
it's it's a myth about the fact that uh
that women
who were looking for sexual liberation
which is very very boring and demanding
long-term loving relationships with
which to have this very nice
safe uh sex which isn't the case at all
like i said we demanded pleasure and an
end to sexual violence and
objectification so what i'm saying about
pornography and also the not just
pornography as i say it's a reflection
of misogyny
and it perpetuates misogyny
but this notion
that
women
can be taught
to enjoy
activities
that are very harmful and very
unenjoyable because that's the narrative
they are being fed
by primarily young men and men of older
generations because it is a
dehumanization of women there is a wider
reflection of of misogyny and inequality
so do julie do you think moving on to
the second topic do you think therefore
a sort of very radical separation of sex
and long-term relationships is dangerous
to society i think we've been doing that
forever
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you